what I wanted to speak about the shorter
summarized here you might fear that it
doesn't fit into 25 minutes we'll see i
do want to start with the rehash of some
work that we used to do earlier about
about predicting gene expression and
predicting gene expression sort of poses
the question predict from what we did
some work i'm predicting from histone
modifications other people did work on
predicting from transcription factor
occupancy in the promoters so i'll
shortly speak about this and the
question that this led us to is can we
can we make use of the co occupancy of
say promoters or locations on the genome
in general by whatever i thinks
transcription factors histone
modifications chromatin associated
proteins be the sequence-specific are
not sequence-specific and so on so how
can we use this and what does it tell us
that will lead us to histone
modification networks I'll speak a bit
more about classical technology for for
network construction extending histone
modifications to chromatin modifiers and
compared to gene networks eventually I
don't need to say much about history
modifications they are these post
translational modifications on on the
histone proteins and it has been known
for quite a while that the histone
modifications are linked to the
transcriptional status of the gene so
there are particular modifications that
that are connected to activation of a
promoter ones that are connected to
repression of a promoter and much like
in the old days we had to learn by heart
which amino acids are hydrophilic and
hydrophobic and large and small nowadays
we have to learn by heart that h3k4
trimethylation is activating and so on
and so forth what do the data really
look like I still like to stare it that
this thing so this is a sort of
minimalistic summary of a genome browser
screen where we have a gene up here the
promoter is approximately here I'll use
this I don't know I like this I always
use no I don't know I think this is much
more visible than this little dot so the
promoter is somewhere here and these are
these famous modifications so for the
ones who are not inside as k562 is a
particular cell line we are in this in
this realm of the dynamic genome
everything we look at here is different
for different cell lines so we always
have to say what the salon is that we
are talking about this is from the
encode data and it makes a lot of sense
to look at information within one and
the same cell line of course so now hjk
for trimethylation is a hallmark of
activation of a promoter and you see
that there are these two peaks in the
promoter region here which probably
correspond roughly to the locations of
to look there's ohms here likewise k27
acetylation is also connected to act to
activation the 27th trimethylation would
be a hallmark of repression and it is
absent here so that already suggests
that we're looking at an active promoter
and the idea that this promoter is
active is then backed up by the
observation that this k36 trimethylation
which is a sign of an ongoing
transcription extends along the gene
body so the whole thing kind of makes a
lot of sense when we look at it and this
is what gives us the idea that we can
use this also to for example predict
gene expression so when we started doing
this that was prompted by the appearance
of the first large-scale data sets which
I'm just siting here that
data set from kg chow who profiled the
whole number of histone modifications in
these cd4 + t cells and also determined
gene expression data at the time it was
still affymetrix data later on one could
also get RNA seek data for this and
basically we said in the lab and we
asked the question well we have all this
time this worked with transcription
factors and we thought that all the
information about the expression of a
gene was was contained in the
transcription factor occupancy in the
promoter what about the histone
modifications could those equally well
tell us something about the expression
status of the gene so when one wants to
propose this question we look at the
promoter we have all the histone
modifications in the promoter and we
want to determine the transcription
level what we really have is we have
tack pounds in those promoter regions a
wreath map ever reads that map into the
promoter region and with these tachyons
we can build a huge matrix which is size
of the number of promoters times the
size of the histone modifications that
that we are studying here a number of
promoters of course is somewhat on the
order of the number of genes 15 to
20,000 usually and after going through
through some very complicated machine
learning schemes we decided to boil it
down to what this I think really simple
we count the tags it turned out in our
hands to be advisable to log transformed
the tag numbers and if we lock transform
we have to of course keep them away from
0 so we introduce a new account and do
linear regression with these log values
and then what one gets is one can
compare the predicted log expression
value to the measured log expression
value and obtains a correlation
coefficient of 0 point seven seven in
this case when one does more
sophisticated things one can push this
data no point seven nine point eight or
so but we figured it wasn't really worth
it to us the the first inside was okay
there is indeed a lot of information
about expression in the histone
modification pattern alone and this was
about the same time when wing wang did a
similar exercise with transcription
factors and he also achieved the
correlation coefficient on this order of
magnitude here and then later on mark
gerstein combined transcription factors
and histone modifications and distance
from the transcription start site but
there seems to be like a magical border
there I mean you can get to add an
appoint a 2.83 or so but you're not
going to make huge jumps by including
more informations there so we figured we
are looking at a somewhat redundant
system and independent of which part of
this redundant system we look at we can
see what is systemic in this mechanism
but we are not going to explain all the
details that the cell knows about one
exercise that we did after that is we
asked well which are the most important
histone modifications for this
prediction so we did feature selection
and on top we found histon for lice in
twenty mono methylation which is for us
good and bad it's good because there's
very little known about it and it's bad
because there's very little known about
it then there's the h3 lysine 27
acetylation where i already said that
it's a it's a hallmark of activation 79
mono methylation is a little bit cheated
because it's already an indicator of the
transcriptional process and we know very
little about this it should be lesson 5
our set elation what was interesting to
see is that in the in the human genome
and and many other mammal warm-blooded
genomes we have this distinction between
CPG Island promoters and promoters that
have a very low CBG contents this is
this famous histogram of the CPG
contents in across all promoters and you
can see
it's very clearly bimodal so there are
really two groups of promoters the low
CPG and the high CPG promoters and we
wanted to stratify our analysis by these
two classes of promoters and what one
finds after doing the same kind of
feature selection is that the CPG rich
promoters can be recognized based on the
age for lesson 20 mono methylation and
the k27 acetylation whereas further for
the low CPG promoters the other
activating mark appears to be more more
important the edge realizing for
trimethylation so that to us seemed like
an interesting distinction the
interpretation that we have for this is
that there is really different dial
chemistry going on because you may you
may be aware of of what is now called
bivalent promoters where there is this
oftentimes under on the CPG rich
promoters you do see the polymerase
sitting there even when the gene is is
off and I think that's what's reflected
here that when you have a CPG rich
promoter and you want to turn that gene
on the task is not to recruit the
polymerase there but to get
transcription started knowing that the
polymerase is already resident on this
promoter and that's different in the CPG
low low CPG promoters where when the
first has to actually get the polymerase
to that particular promoter so that it
really seems to be different
biochemistry going on there so that was
a few years back and and and at that
time we were also a little bit
frustrated or intimidated by all these
histone modifications because we had
selected these particular supposedly
important histone modifications but at
the same time when you look at genome
browser output you see that they are
very strong some of them are very
strongly correlated with each other so
this is a correlation plot of all these
histone modifications across all the
promoters which we looked at so behind
each dot there's the correlation of two
vectors of length
fifteen thousand or so and obviously
very very clear clusters like up here
there is a highly correlated cluster of
of modifications and you can see that
there's for example here the h3 lysine
27 acetylation which was this activating
one so clearly that is a cluster of
modifications that are connected to
activation of the genes and on the
opposite end of the scale
anti-correlated to the activating ones
we have for example h3 lysine 27
trimethylation which is the hallmark of
the repressive ones so again there is a
whole group of of repressive marks yes
we know whether that correlation is
interesting biology or whether it
possibly could arise from antibody non
specificity and things like that or it
can we get back to that yeah yes comment
on the fact that you have a very good
correlation between all the positive
factors but not a very strong
correlation between the negative ones
right so you have the upper left view if
you can go back one once life so there
is a good correlation in the upper right
you mean the asymmetry between one here
and negative point five here yeah I mean
the same type of of correlation between
the negative factors too right
I don't know yes I I see a point I don't
have an answer for this
so here's a small excursion to stuff
that we did more years back and it were
published in 2003 and and that was
prompted by the the first chip chip
experiments that were done in the lab of
Rick young on on yeast where he had a
produced chip chip data for a whole
range of transcription factors in yeast
so for those of you who don't know cheap
cheap anymore its chromatin IP where you
obtain the sequences not by sequencing
but by hybridizing to the microarray a
trip so that's why why there was the
possibility to use to make this little
part of chip chip and at the time we
thought our this is cool we have always
been interested in cooperativity of
transcription factors remember the
beginning I was saying do things on the
DNA co-occur we were we were interested
in the cooperativity of transcription
factor so we just asked the question
whether there are pairs of transcription
factors which I find on the same within
the same window of sequence possibly a
promoter more often than expected
statistically so at the time we computed
the log odds core between the expected
frequency of these co-occurrence and the
observed frequency of co-occurrence and
when this log odds call indicated that
the co-occurrence was sort of not to be
expected than we were drawing edges in
some graph of all the transcription
factors and to convince ourselves that
this is actually meaningful information
on the one hand we compared it to the
protein-protein interaction data and it
did overlap very strongly with the
protein-protein interaction data and
here it's just colored by by go category
so that one can see that transcription
factors that are involved in the same
processes appear to co-occur here so
they probably physically interact so
this co-occurrence philosophy does show
us a
the probably the real cooperativity
between the transcription factors at
least we then generalize this to
mammalian systems where we are to
basically two methods or own systems
where we had to stratify by the tissue
if you wouldn't stratify by tissue you
couldn't get at the information what we
did is we predicted the transcription
factor binding sites based on the motifs
and and checked which genes were
expressed a in the lung or in the liver
and for the lung expressed promoters we
then did the analysis for the
co-occurring transcription factors and
that allowed us to also compute such
interaction networks of transcription
factors here is for him at the paralysis
because we did it for a whole lot of
libraries and again this works pretty
well so it was another indicator to us
that looking at the co-occurrence
pattern of the transcription factors
actually provides us with good
biological information so here we are
also asking a question about the
co-occurrence of the modifications but
what we are what we were worried about
here is that because we just studied the
correlations when I have one thing
correlated to a second one and that in
turn correlated to a third one in all
likelihood I'm also going to observe a
correlation between the first and the
third but what we're really after is we
won sort of mechanistically we want to
find out where other biochemical
connections what is mechanistically
going on so we want to get rid of these
transitively induced edges and in fact
getting rid of the transitively induced
correlations is is an old subject and
that has already been answered by Fisher
and others early in 1907 or something
like this I learned and the mechanism
there is called partial correlation
coefficients so when we have a matrix
this is now like one histone
modification across all promoters and
other histone modifications and so on
our problem is that when we do of this
correlation coefficients we make it
spurious edges between groups of these
columns and the cut and the partial the
idea of the partial correlation
coefficient is that one first when one
studies like the blue and the red column
from here when first regress is the blue
column on the other two columns regreses
the red on the other two columns and
obtains residuals and what we're really
interested in is the correlation of the
residuals because that will will help us
to get rid of these transitively induced
edges so basically we can eliminate
edges that we are not interested in
those of you who are familiar with the
literature in machine learning or
graphical models know all this and in
it's very easy to compute this for a
larger set of data because one neat
there's no necessity to sort of compute
the partial correlation coefficients on
foot one can use the the inverse of the
variance covariance matrix and as a nice
relationship between the partial
correlation coefficients and the inverse
of the variance covariance matrix of the
variance covariance matrix of these
vectors here and the the reason why this
is of interest and that's what i call it
here is the theorem on the computation
and there's the theorem on the meaning
that when the data comes from a
multivariate normal then the partial
correlation is zero exactly when the
variables are conditionally independent
and that's really what we want to get it
we want to find those errors that are
conditionally independent because in
networker construction one always
eliminates those edges which are
conditionally
here's an example with numbers
unfortunately when I converted this in
PDF it doesn't layer it anymore so we
just to show that this is really
concrete yeah yuliana panda who was
making this slide for her PhD defense
she generated data we have these four
columns the first column is drawn from a
standard normal the second column is
generated with another normal from the
values in the first one and then the
third one is generated with another
normal from the second one and the
fourth one is generated from the third
one so the network actually is a chain
the way it is simulated and then when we
do all the correlation coefficients or
covariances here this is the matrix that
we get and you can see that that the
effect of this simulation here gets
accumulated along the edges and we would
sort of predict a complete network here
the the theorem behind it of course is
sort of the standard theorem that in
Gaussian data when the correlation
coefficient of covariance e 0 then the
variables are independent but what we
want to have is we want the conditional
independence which is given only when
the inverse of the various cove
covariance matrix has a zero entry and
unfortunately because I couldn't build
it up slowly anymore you can you cannot
really see the coefficients you see that
sum becomes 0 and the ones that becomes
0 are exactly the edges that we are not
interested in like from x 2 to x 4 or
from x 1 to x 4 and on top of that
between between the variables that
actually are connected you get to see
with a negative sign that you get to see
the real coefficient of the generating
process here that the point for the
point 5 the generated x4 from x3 gets
recovered by by the inverse of the
variance covariance matrix this is just
an illustration I don't know maybe I'm
not enough of a mathematician to just
believe the
minocin this is the real numbers so what
if we do that on data yeah the data now
is basically this matrix a bit larger
yeah it's 15,000 promoters high and some
30 or 40 i don't remember modifications
and other seeing things wide that's our
data and not much has been done to this
data so this is the result that we
obtained blue is an anti coordination
now red is a positive correlation and I
added a few other variables that are not
modifications for the sake of
interpretability like here is the mRNA
level of the gene next to the promoter
where we collected the data so what we
see for example is mrna is negatively
correlated to the repressive mark a27
trimethylation that's good yeah the
repressive mark is negatively correlated
to the active mark that's also good then
we have for example the age for license
when team on a methylation that is
positively correlated to to mrna level
and you may remember in our first
analysis h4 license when dimana
methylation was an important predictor
k27 acetylation here was an important
predictor k 79 here is mono methylation
here it since the I methylation in this
data set is positively also positively
correlated to the mRNA level on the
other hand so in that respect it all
makes sense and we can can just from
visual inspection see what's what's are
mostly influencing the mRNA one can see
other things for example that there's a
cluster of a city very tight cluster of
acetylation here that is totally this
joint from the k-27 our situation yes
if you threshold this next slide okay
and then we for example included dnase
hypersensitivity because we were worried
that many effects that we see are just
due to the accessibility of the DNA and
I think that actually what one sees hear
the term of the modification seem to be
very closely connected like the h3k4
trimethylation seems to be closely
connected to the hype to the
accessibility and likewise this age for
less than 20 mono methylation so I I
don't think that that means that the
results are bogus but my interpretation
is that they are hard to quantify in
those regions I cannot really say this
modification is strong or a weaker than
another one because very much of it is
dominated by the accessibility as such
and then there are effects where we also
speculate that they have to do with
antibody cross-reactivity like these
strong correlations between the KFOR
mono methylation daya methylation and
trimethylation so that may on the one
hand it may be due to the fact that one
always looks at mixtures of sales but it
may also be due to antibody
cross-reactivity so this is what what
happens when one doesn't look at
correlation coefficients but when one
uses this mechanism of the inverse of
the variance covariance matrix to look
at partial correlations it doesn't quite
work the way it's in the book normally
very much so because we have this funny
shaped matrix and first of all the
theory always expects Gaussian data
which for the for the histone
modifications when you look at the
distributions of the histone
modification tag numbers some are sort
of okay others are bimodal others look
totally different we resorted to rank
sorting the data that means we don't
really compute a correlation coefficient
but rather compute a rank correlation
coefficient but the rest still works
the other problem is that our vectors
have the size of like 15,000 or so the
number of promoters so all the p-values
for the for the correlation coefficients
are bogus yeah we get these the stuff
that people love to report I have a
p-value of 10 to the minus 200 and so it
doesn't really make a lot of sense to
threshold the edges on the p-values and
what we did instead is yes we do a
threshold on some but some arbitrary p
value but then we r e sample from the
promoters and in the end of the edges
that we show are the edges that in the
resampling occur them more than like
seventy percent of the times that of the
bootstrap samples that we used and that
in our hands turned out to be a fairly
stable thing and then work much better
than actually actually using these bogus
p values from these huge vectors so
those were the little technical details
to get this working I don't know any
that I start time at with time
so very quickly now I mean historically
the way we we developed all this yuliana
panna gave a seminar about this paper
from the broad I think some people
co-authors are here and they did I ps4
chromatin Associated enzymes and then
let's keep this then I thought I thought
well this may not be very imaginative
but we know how to predict gene
expression from the histone
modifications and if I assume that the
histone modification itself is a product
of the chromatin associated a chromatin
modifying enzymes I can model the hope
based on modification in much the same
way as initially we remodeled the the
gene expression but there's not one
histone modification there is many
histone modifications since I did the
slide myself I stopped at two and but
then we are not really interested in all
these edges here yeah we want to somehow
thin out these edges and that's why when
we do the regression now we use battery
gresham and herbs that's gum okay there
should be another one where some of
these edges disappear and we get some
something like in network just by using
sparse regression and this again I think
is sort of biologically a very very
informative network now the rectangular
nodes are the histone modifications the
oval nodes are the chromatin associated
the proteins many of them are enzymes
that actually do something on the
modifications and we have arranged the
arrow such that it's always the
chromatin modifiers that do something to
the histone modification we have not
computed you have not computed the arrow
directions and you can see for example
here you see the polycom complex yeah
ezh2 Sue's 12 and the CB axis which set
h3 lysine 27 trimethylation
here you have an activating layer that
that works positively on these
modifications and you have a repressive
layer which counteracts this activating
layer that sort of that that changes the
modifications the activating
modifications for the repressive
modifications and then it becomes easier
to understand when when overlays it with
the partial correlations from before you
still see here the polycomb complex but
you can see interesting detail that
biochemically has been much very very
involved to show for example that the
polymerase without the syrian five
phosphorylation is associated to
regulation on the promoter so its
associated to the k27 acetylation or to
end up to the k-9 acetylation whereas
this here is the polymerase with the
syrian five phosphorylation that is
associated to the k 79 die methylation
sorry hit the k 79th I methylation and
the k36 trimethylation so that is the
process of transcription in the
transcription cycle which are angela
just showed so one can clearly see these
associations when following along the
DNA here so i think this becomes quite
interpretable and in fact these thought
the solid lines here are edges for which
one finds support in the literature and
the dotted lines are edges for which x
per student did not find any support in
the literature so for example for these
two edges another lab in our Institute
and did a try the experimental
validation and I won't explain this but
it did actually works these edges can
can be backed up experimentally although
this has never been sort of observed or
never been made a topic of research
until now so this brings me to the end
but what I really want to stress to
summer in summary is I I think I didn't
show anything technically in you the
a interesting twist is that all this
this machinery for computation of
networks has been applied a lot to
computation of networks on jeans a
transcript data for example yeah where
we have thousands of genes and we have a
handful of conditions and from this we
want to compute networks on the genes
this of course is extremely hard because
there's just a lack of information the
the situation that I've described to you
is where we have our computing networks
on a small number of histone marks
chromatin associated proteins you name
it but we have data from all the
promoters in the genome so we have ample
data and that's why the very
straightforward methods actually work
well and give us interesting information
about the underlying biology and then
maybe anyway I did show you the names in
the beginning those were the people who
really did the work and this is the
group thank you very much for your
attention
there's correlations so if you use
promoters as your observations then it
is known that there is significant
correlation in the activity also between
rising neighboring genes depending on
how close they are on the chromosome and
then also how close they are in the 3d
space of the nuclear so if you look at
any of those how they relate to the
correlation because if any in principle
there should be some of those edges that
are distributing well along the
chromosome some of them they are very
local we haven't looked at correlations
between like neighboring genes or if you
are thinking of correlations in
expression within a tad or so we didn't
look at that not in this context we have
a recent paper where we do not only look
at promoters but have segmented the
genome and do the networks within the
different segments so say whatever it
may be enhancers promoters and so on and
look at the individual networks and and
integrate between those networks what
are the common features between the
chromosomal segments but that again then
is across the entire genome so we are
not we have not yet succeeded in merging
this way of looking at the data with the
3d topology and the tans
kind of a related question but somewhat
different a lot of the analysis was of
the structure of these networks for
promoters have you looked at enhancers
and do they seem to exhibit the same
kinds of correlations or they just where
do they have different correlations it
is that well I think it's sort of one of
these historical coincidence is that
where we looked at the enhancer was a
totally different data set so we did
find it thats a paper in in cell reports
recently the we find interesting
relationships for with the different
methylation forms you know hydroxymethyl
ation and so on and that seems to be
also very important in the promote in
lille enhancers for example you are
right we should have stuck to the same
framework here and done that on the
enhancers somehow we skipped that so
that's why we cannot really compare we
had another maybe that's of interesting
in the context of your question we made
another experience in in a cancer
epigenetics project where the the
postdoc who was working on this project
was computing these networks for the
promoters of the cancerous cell line and
our were saying why do you do this this
is biochemistry the biochemistry is
going to be the same in the cancer cell
so you're not going to find anything and
so he did it nevertheless and came back
with a very interesting observation
because one of the edge is basically
disappeared and then we try to
understand why and we found out that the
particular enzyme that sets this
modification was mutated in that form of
cancer so I was wrong the cancer cell
has different our chemistry possibly and
it helped to do the network and see this
I just want basic Marshall so here you
showed with a histone modification there
were still some transitive engines and I
wonder if you think there's a real or
lisa.marta fact that I could be mr.
distant event that was in particular for
the cluster of acetylation for example
normally you wouldn't expect any yeah
yeah there's two reasons for that one is
our threshold in that that works with
this bootstrapping that may introduce
such effects but also when you when you
look into the literature about the
partial correlations you you you can
produce people report that you can
produce all kinds of funny situations
also where where the intuitive positive
positive then the third one has to be
positive as well is not gonna hold so
these things do happen III don't we have
never attributed much importance to it
in this context here I must admit but it
does happen that's true it's sort of
just a weird glitch or anything is there
should should we be doing a statistic
that's not paralyzed so now i'm looking
at higher order effects
I i would rather think it's a weird
glitch I don't think there's much to
gain but I mean as I just said sometimes
my judgment was totally wrong follow
right I mean it's not it doesn't follow
that if the underlying graph of the
direct interactions in the in the in the
multivariate Gaussian has loops in it
does it mean that there are higher order
terms like that it's not that what you
can just have such things appear it's
not a you can have it statistically as
you say yeah from the underlying
distributions and I think biologically
it can be if you would have different
groups of promoters that stress
different kinds of modifications those
can contribute individual edges and when
you all put it into one network you can
see this very clustering over the
promoters would be a good thing there
are you did your computation on ranks so
how much of the theory of graphical
model still holds when you compute on
ranks for example saying that the
missing link is conditional independence
assets to hope I don't I I don't have
Gaussian data so basically I've given up
on the theory at a much earlier point in
time we've done very fairly extensive
simulations on the effect of the rank
ordering and our our experience was that
we lose very little power by the rank
ordering so I think given that that we
cannot make the data Gaussian it's about
it's a cheap thing to do there are also
other people that do it I mean
afterwards of course you never read
these things beforehand but afterwards I
started to learn that the psychologists
have been doing this for ages and they
also do the rank transformation and the
Holies
so yeah this is your lame question right
so that some of these marks I remember
our disabilities are by model when you
actually look the dissolution so you
could also try to sort of like letting
map you to Hyneria variables and then do
something like aggression it yeah burn
so we started with other we started with
mutual information yeah and and for the
bimodal ones it's easy to have a
threshold and binarize the data but then
there are others where there is no
obvious threshold so somehow the problem
the underlying problem is you want to
compute the network where part of the
data is almost gaussian and the other
part should be modeled with mutual
information because it's easy to
threshold it and get a binary signal but
but you don't really I mean you have to
mix these variables so I think the rank
correlation is a cheap way of mixing
these two types of variables
one is some of these marks act on
different regions like the K 79 marks
are aging body so
we later on did it with just going like
five hundred two thousand but 500 paces
into after the TSS and it doesn't really
change the results of course then the
the the transcription extension signals
disappear because you don't get them
anymore but the rest remains the same
second question is you earlier showed
the difference between high seeking
promoters and low CP promoters and the
policy of halton so later only to go
back and did your networks for two types
of promoters and see if you see the
power to affect yeah yeah actually we
had done a lot of that and the reviewers
basically said uninteresting get rid of
it and yes I we think that when the seed
is different biochemistry and when one
when when stratifies the network
computation also on the different kinds
of promoters I think that holds through
I should at some point dig out the old
figures that didn't make it into the
paper and include